Jeremiah makes 25% of the three-point
shots he attempts far better than my
percentage for warmup
Jeremiah likes to shoot three-point
shots until he successfully makes one
all right this is a telltale signs of a
geometric random variables how many
trials do have to take until I get a
success let M be the number of shots it
takes Jeremiah to successfully make his
first three-point shot okay so they're
defining the random variable here the
number of shots it takes a number of
trials it takes until we get a
successful three-point shot assume that
the results of each shot are independent
all right the probability that he makes
a given shot is not dependent on whether
he made or missed the previous shots
find the probability that Jeremiah's
first successful shot occurs on his
third attempt so like always pause this
video and see if you could have a go at
it
alright now let's work through this
together so we want to find the
probability that so M is the number of
shots it takes until Jeremiah makes his
first successful one and so what they're
really asking is find the probability
that M is equal to 3 that his first
successful shot occurs on his third
attempt so M is equal to 3 so that the
number of shots it takes jera not my to
make it successful his first successful
shot is 3 so how do we do this well well
what's just the probability of that
happening well that means he has to miss
his first two shots and then make his
third shot so what's the probability of
him missing his first shot well if he
has a 1/4 chance of making his shots he
has a 3/4 he has a 3/4 probability of
missing his shots so this will be 3/4 so
he misses the first shot times he has to
miss the second shot and then he has to
make his third shot so there you have it
that's the probability miss miss make
so what is this going to be this is
equal to nine over sixty fourths so
there you have it if you wanted to have
this as a decimal we could get a
calculator out real fast so this is nine
whoops nine divided by 64 is equal to
zero
roughly 0.14 approximately 0.14 or
another way to think about it is a
roughly fourteen percent chance or
fourteen percent probability that it
takes him that his first successful shot
occurs in his third attempt